with over 300 sessions at next 2023 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see accelerate
software development with vertex ai's
Cod apis then stay tuned because here's
the
rewind the vertex AI Cody apis can
provide code completion code generation
and code chat capabilities and a variety
of programming languages all in the IDE
of your choice and with support for
customization you can tune the model
with your own
data the code completion API suggests
code completions based on the context of
the code being written it's low latency
code assistance that can help provide
the current and next few lines of code
and can be used to improve your speed
and
accuracy code generation generates code
based on a natural language description
of the desired code and unlike code
completion with code generation you can
create a complete block of code which is
great for various tasks like creating
apis building web apps and more and
we've recently added model quality
improvements and streaming with a longer
context window and code chat allows
developers to converse with a bot to get
help with code related questions which
can help with unit tests debugging
documentation and even learning to code
and with our commitment to responsible
AI all the apis have source citation and
toxicity Checker to site and identify
sources used in the generated code and
filter harmful content comments and
code all the models are running in
Google cloud and accessible from model
garden and can be tested quickly in
vertex geni
Studio the recent model refresh has also
expanded the use cases that we support
and customers can use the apis across
the software development life cycle
integrated in ide used via duet AI IDE
plugins vertex collab and even cicd
workflows in almost any language with
vertex ai's adapter tuning service which
is significantly faster than full
fine-tuning customers can help improve
llm performance with as few as 100
examples and of course customers keep
the data set we have options of adapter
tuning for the Cod models too you can
generate code using custom libraries use
your own code base to customize the base
model and further improve model
quality adapt the base model to generate
code in language variants to use your
standards and with the new text tosql
we've added an online inference only
pipeline to code generation for SQL
prompts so you can convert natural
language to SQL and execute the SQL
queries using the big query or BQ engine
which selects the most consistent
response based on the executed
results if you'd like to see the full
talk check out the links in the
description and don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more great next rewind content thanks
for
watching